back here on the Rich Eisen show one of
our favorite guests because he always
spits truth and his 49ers by the way are
the only remaining undefeated team in
the NFC on their bye week they sat back
and watch the Rams lose not once but
twice and they take on the Rams next
week but they finish up this week and a
Monday Night Football spot a big game
against the Cleveland Browns Pro Bowler
Richard Sherman back here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Richard I'm doing
great I'm fine I'm wondering do you when
you watch a Thursday night game like
last night involving your former team do
you root for the Seahawks sitting there
watching it I didn't even wants to the
game out of three no really no I try not
to watch football for free time huh
because I'd imagine you use your next
team that you're you're facing after
this one so you didn't even watch the
Thursday Night Football game no I don't
care to watch TV copy I'll get that I
get to all 22 after the game they'll
send to my pad I'll take a look at their
free time so you're hanging with your
families what you're saying instead of
watching football you're being you're
being Daddy not cornerback right all
right so were you watching Disney Junior
or something instead of a fox Peppa Pig
I think was there yeah that's right
I'm getting ready for London speaking of
Peppa Pig I'm gonna be doing that London
game next week so it's sitting here at
3:00 and oh right now Richard does there
is there any feeling that around this
team that you have felt before in
championship years in your previous spot
I mean I don't try to compare it to
anything you know where ever a good time
with Lang good football we're enjoying
playing one another that's always good
feeling you know the fact that we're
winning games is obviously a plus
looking forward to this next game
getting another opportunity to go out
there and compete okay and in terms of
what you're seeing on film of the Browns
what are you seeing on film of the
Browns well they did a great job of
executing that game plan last week
against the Ravens obviously got in
gotcha involved he made a lot of good
big plays got Landry involved for the
most part his spots and he got very
creative with the way they allowed Baker
to swing the ball around so
it was look like they found a good
rhythm what challenge for a does Odell
present to you Richard when you're
across from him well he's a great
receiver runs Chris route he's explosive
can always go distance it because you
know if left with it would have seemed
so uh you know make sure you stay stay
up and stay on him
idle thoughts well I know it's season
nine for you but do you get a particular
competitive edge by facing somebody like
Odell well I mean you know every shoot
every week people facing by great Nestle
basically receiver a great quarterback
or combination of both so it's obviously
going to be a great challenge that you
know you always can appreciate every
year and every came looking forward to
it and are you gonna wear a watch of
some sort no no I don't wear watches go
for keeps time no I understand that but
I mean I think that that might be a way
to get in his in his in his helmet
Richard like you sure you show up with a
watch and flash it to him as he's
getting ready to to run a route don't
you think that would be helpful
right right right that might be that
that might be there I'm just saying I'm
not saying that you need one but maybe
maybe you could take a watch maybe if
you're if one of your small children has
a watch
you could wear one of those and get out
there what do you think of that you know
that's that's part of my game plan I'm
gonna think about it I'm gonna uh you
know see what I can do nothing you know
look I just try to leave people in a
better spot than I found there hey
you've been quite vocal and I'm sure you
knew I would bring this up but you've
been very vocal on the fair pay to play
act that the governor of our state of
California has signed into law and you
said that if this is the death of the
NCAA then then that's a good thing why
do you feel that way well because it's
it's a corrupt institution you know and
they've been taking advantage of these
kids for a really long time you know
they they go under the guise of a fair
play and managing it and you know every
every week you you look up and there's
something else going on we're we're kids
getting taken advantage of I mean they
could
even let kids get meals for a for a
while there you know I mean when I was
in college it was illegal by NC double-a
standards for the team to even provide
more than one meal a day like that that
doesn't seem like a like a super
advantage you know that seems like
something that would be reasonably
expected from a university is to to feed
their their athletes in NC double-a is
the kind of institution that wouldn't
even let them what didn't see it be fair
or fit for universities to be able to
feed their athletes until I think I
forget who one of the kids that in the
March Madness tournament was like I
starve every night you know i starved
most night you know and he had just won
a national championship and there was
like oh well this is a bad look publicly
so let us change this dump
rule this archaic rule and I think that
until people really get inside inside
look at the NC double-a and what they do
with the money and and how much money is
made per athlete per player per team
then people won't really fully
understand this the scope of things you
know people will continue to say well
the half leads get scholarships well
some of these scholarships are worth ten
thousand dollars fourteen thousand
dollars twenty thousand dollars and
these kids are working working
ridiculous hours especially in football
they're working ridiculous hours every
weekend and really are getting
compensated fairly and it's obviously
it's a huge huge industry in terms of
finances you know it's a multi-billion
dollar industry so it's not just gonna
come down easy you know there are people
making 1015 million dollars a year
easy money off the backs of these kids
they're not gonna let that stop well i
and and in terms of your situation in
college richard i mean in terms of
juggling big-time athletics and big-time
academics i mean stanford has to be that
one of the the most difficult to
actually navigate would you have had
time to do other things to be paid to
get paying gigs on the side Richard no
but I think honestly I didn't have time
to do anything because because your
schedule is dependent on time of year
whether it's winter or NCS or spring
ball you know you got time to wake up
and if you're in the winter you got
winter conditioning at 6:00 a.m. that
starts at 6:00 a.m. so you have to work
wake up at 5:30 get there get dressed
the beat to practice F 6:30 I mean six
that will probably end at 7:30
you have class at 8:15 8:30 you you're
in class you're doing your on your thing
so you probably have meetings at 2
o'clock so you got you can't have any
classes from from 2:00 to probably 4 or
5 o'clock and which is impossible in
college but that's a requirement so you
know it's it you don't have time to
really do anything because your schedule
is always filled with with football or
workouts or lifts or you know they keep
you busy so but I think the big thing
that will change is that the NCAA won't
be able to use your likeness they
profited for a long time just putting
putting Ezekiel Elliott or whoever the
star player is Cara Maria or whoever the
guy is for that year on the cover of
magazines on a cover of tickets on on
the sides of stadiums
you know putting them in and in
commercials to sell games and things
like that and I think that will change
fundamentally when they have to pay
these kids to do that well you can show
the universities but you can't show the
kid well you know Richard Sherman here
in the Rich Eisen show I'm with you
lockstep with this whole thing but I do
want to play devil's advocate if you
will while I have you on the phone line
the other arguments that one is hearing
about this is that the competitive
imbalance would be thrown off for
instance let's say Stanford where you
know you have been on record where it's
not as intense of a football environment
to say the SEC how how in the world
could Stanford stay competitive if you
will if there's a school that's giving a
million dollars through the a car
dealership to come and and play at the
University how can i if we're gonna be
specific I would argue that Stanford
Alabama goes for two different styles
kids and recruits two different styles
kids you know I'd say they're very few
times that Stanford in Alabama or
recruiting the same kind of kid and the
same exact athlete so I think that that
in itself would never would ever play
out
you said USC in Alabama and are fighting
for kids and guess what one of the one
of those universities with kids and you
could say that all you want but every
every week you look at these coaches and
commercials these college coaches these
amateur coaches of these universities
sitting in commercials getting
million-dollar deals getting
million-dollar car deals getting there
and I don't see anybody saying anything
about a competitive advantage so I find
it odd that you say that there's a
competitive advantage when the kids when
these student athletes are involved but
never when the coaches are involved and
that's that that's what's odd about this
whole thing like half the time they say
oh it's amateur but when you involve
coaches who were Forex NFL coaches
sometimes then all of a sudden a the
coaches are professional so they get to
do endorsement deals they get to get
side deals with with car dealerships our
commercials are or any kind of
endorsement deals they want but when you
go to the kids that they coach the kids
are amateur a couple more minutes left
here with Richard Sherman 49ers
cornerback right here on the Rich Eisen
show so when it all comes down to it I
know you've got a professional dropped
it to how do you see this all playing
out I mean the NCAA has taken one side
and California's done it's law and there
are other states that are gonna be
probably doing the same thing there's
one in Anthony Gonzalez former Ohio
State wide receiver is a congressman
who's beginning to fashion federal law
on this how do you think this all winds
up with Richard well I don't think
they're you know the n-c-double-a like I
said is a billion-dollar industry and
when you have money you have power so
they'll have political PACs in place to
try to protect themselves and try to
fight this legislation but I don't think
that the n-c-double-a is in law the
n-c-double-a isn't it isn't the federal
government you know it's it this
institution it's a private institution
or nonprofit or whatever the case may be
so I think that this law if this law
passes in California other states will
be lockstep and it will either destroy
the n-c-double-a and if it destroys the
insight double-a then another
organization will come in and manage
college football in a more reasonable
way and
things that should should have been
allowed you know you're kicking kids out
for having YouTube channels and
suspending kids for doing things that
regular students are able to do and
you're ending these kids college careers
you know when they're not doing anything
out of the ordinary they're not doing
anything extra this kid is filming
videos of him kicking kicking a football
and now he can't now you can't play
college football because he's monetizing
something that is a talent of his that's
outside of this game and I think that
once once all that said said and done
either the n-c-double-a will fold or
they will change their ways
substantially and become the institution
that they should have been in the first
place and even the president today said
well maybe we should change ten years
ago but hey we weren't we weren't the
position change like they were you've
been in a position change forever but
when you don't have to change you don't
last thing for you Richard what's the
status of the CVA conversations and
they've been tabled between the Players
Association in the NFL for the season
where does that stand right now yeah
they've been tabled for the season so
we'll resume probably for talking all
season once you know everybody's done
there are a few discussions between you
know de and Eric and Roger but for the
two executive committees getting in
terms of to the executive committee to
getting together it won't be happen
anytime soon okay it'll happen after the
49ers bring another Lombardi Trophy back
to Northern California is that okay just
want to make sure I'm going to write
that down
sorry I'm a little salty JJ Watt sent me
this mug with his face on it because
Michigan got destroyed by Wisconsin and
you know it's a tough one for me to take
Richard but I'm I'm gonna take it like a
man you know take care of Richard thanks
for the time as always to truly enjoy
our chats thank you right back at you
art our Sherman underscore 25 for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app